we are no one we are ever
one and we are invisible we convinced
ourselves that they were gone but they
were just hibernating they came for
everybody oh please
obviously
I guess we have ourselves for reckoning
[Applause]
what are you two talking about oh
nothing just the end of the world
hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna go
back and breakdown Watchmen HBO's first
trailer there's been a slow drip of
information coming out about Damon
Lindelof stake on the iconic Watchmen
series to this point but I am expecting
that we're gonna get a lot more during
the upcoming comic-con in San Diego this
weekend so this trailer is a couple
months old but for the sake of
completeness I wanted to break it down
scene by scene because that's the thing
I like to do before we begin this will
contain spoilers for the original
Watchmen comic series slash book I made
a video explaining why I think you
should read it before you dive into the
show if you haven't done that already
and I strongly recommend this I'll put a
link up top to that it probably takes
less than eight hours to get through and
I think it's completely worth it
Watchmen on HBO probably won't premiere
until October so you do have time and
there's no real way to break down this
trailer without spoiling the ending of
the original Watchmen story so this is
the final warning now let's break down
the trailer scene-by-scene
the trailer opens with a close-up shot
of a man wearing a homemade mask that
looks similar to the one the character
Rorschach wears in the original comic I
used the word homemade because the
original mask was made with a futuristic
fabric where the black and white moved
around under the surface but never mixed
together it's clear that the masks and
the trailers aren't made of that and
therefore are likely a tribute to
Rorschach who died at the end of the
comic before his death he mailed his
journal to a right-wing newspaper and
this opening sequence appears to
indicate that it was eventually
published as the shot pans out we see
that there is a whole gang of people
wearing Rorschach mass and we hear the
first voice over we are no one we are
everyone and we are invisible behind the
gang which looks to be all men we see a
crucifixion that has the words of Psalm
65 above it prays waiteth for the Oh God
in Zion we see that they're occupying an
old church and this verse definitely
adds some cult-like vibes the
crucifixion is tilted which could be a
nod to a clock just past midnight
the next scene is of a pocketwatch the
character is holding it gives it a flick
with his finger and we see that the time
is nine minutes to midnight after the
flick we hear a mantra like repetition
of the words - Tok Tik Tok and those
carry on throughout most of the trailer
the original watchman book used repeated
images of clocks counting down to
midnight so this seems like a nod to
that but in his letter to fans about the
project Lindelof said that the end of
the world was off the table I'll talk a
little more about that in the discussion
after we get through all the scenes in
the next shot we see a new character
Chief Judge Nelson addressing a roomful
of masked police officers he says we
convinced ourselves that they were gone
but they were just hibernating the chief
himself isn't wearing a mask but it
appears that all the other officers are
when we scan the room my guess is that
his words refer to the Rorschach's over
at the church who we see again in the
next scene we watch them rolling out of
a van and moving together as a group
they're armed and we see one of them
pump a shotgun as they go the sequence
is short and there aren't a lot of
visual clues as to where they are or who
they're approaching chief Nelson's
voiceover continues saying they came for
everybody all police as he's speaking we
cut from the Rorschach's to a cemetery
where a police funeral is taking place
it looks like most of the funeral goers
are police officers and they are all
wearing their masks we catch a quick
glimpse of the American flag on the
casket we see that the stars are
arranged in a circle and that coupled
with the shot of the Washington Monument
with the Skywalk built around the top of
it serve as a reminder that even though
the watchman universe resembles our
world that it is indeed an alternate
reality this brings to mind the
cigarettes or the fast-food being
different in the graphic novel small
hints that the world looks the same but
is actually different from there we cut
to the character kal Abraham asking his
wife Angela are we safe and we see them
embrace this looks like a possible
flashback to a time before the fighting
between the Rorschach's and the police
picked up they look happy and it cuts to
a night shot of Angela looking intense
in her car which is obviously a contrast
to the couple being together then we see
her full costume in a locker which looks
like a callback to the comics when
Rorschach discovers the comedian's
costume or like the night
locker in his workshop it's not clear
where she keeps her costume but we see
Angela Donna in the next scene and when
you notice that it includes her badge
and that she wears a pair of beads
around her waist from there we get a
full shot of her mask at a crime scene
and a new voiceover cuts in this sounds
like the actor who plays the new
character looking-glass and says I guess
we have ourselves a reckoning this comes
along with our first shot of Looking
Glass with his mask that looks like a
wearable mirror more or less he appears
to work for the police alongside Angela
and we'll get a better look at him in a
minute there's a quick shot of a truck
driving away from a residence not much
we can gather from this but it looks
like there are police stationed at the
end of the drive as a protective measure
we get another glimpse of a new
character named Special Agent Blake in
the next scene she appears to be looking
at a laptop with a heavy-duty case Blake
is the last name of the comedian from
the original story that leaves us to
guess that there's probably a family
connection the timings weird though
since the story takes place 30 years
after the original story it's not
exactly clear how these two could be
related comedian was a member of the
Minutemen in 1939 he died in 1985 and he
would be pushing like a hundred if he
was still alive right now the actress
who plays Special Agent Blake is in her
late 60's so your guess is as good as
mine after that there's a shot of a
carnival with a bunch of people laying
around on the ground like they dropped
exactly where they were standing
I say laying around because they
certainly could be dead but there aren't
any signs of violence no blood no smoke
no impact craters just people on the
ground if you zoom in and look closely
there are some flames on a vehicle of
some sort and a couple random people
standing up looking around really can't
say for sure what's going on here
there's a quick look at a kitchen timer
that's going off with a loud ringing
then we get our first look at the
costume adventurers amanda is a ka
Adrian Veidt who is the one original
character that we know is returning he's
meditating which we've seen him do in
the past the last time we saw him do
this it was after he sent a giant squid
to kill millions of people in New York
City
he killed millions to save billions in
his point of view and this trailer could
be hinting
he has another plan like that in mind we
see a foreign soldier looking fellow
striking a match on his shoe he looks
like he would be a leader or a officer
in the military of some unknown country
and by this time the kitchen timer alarm
and the Rorschach's tic TOCs are getting
pretty intense we see Angela and a
camper attack an unknown character who
isn't wearing a mask
it looks like the B's she wears on her
waist our weapon and they look pretty
effective as she strikes this guy and
that leads us into an action-packed
sequence where it's a bunch of stuff
going on first we see lights lit up
around what looks like a farmhouse there
are cows an old car in the yard and some
blazing lights inside the tree line we
see the chief shield his eyes which
means he might be on the scene
witnessing this all go down then there's
a cut to Ozymandias riding a horse past
a pirate flag that is hanging from a
side this feels like a reference to the
pirate comic inside the Watchmen comic
called the black freighter but that
doesn't really explain why Adrian is
riding a horse past it we also see a
shot of what I'm guessing is Aussie /
Adrian's castle from a distance and
those two shots are probably connected
then we cut back to the farmhouse and
see that the Rorschach's have brought
the big guns literally they have what
looks like a 50 caliber machine gun
which would be bad news for anyone it's
pointed at and they are unloading some
bullets we transition to some unfamiliar
new characters looking up at the sky one
of them's holding a baby this directly
follows the machine-gun scene but they
don't look like the targets based on the
fact that they're not running for cover
after that we see what looks like the
night-owls airship Archie falling from
the sky engulfed in flames this is
interesting on a lot of levels since
there's been no mention of night owl or
Silk Spectre in the casting we've seen
so far even though both characters could
still be alive the ship will apparently
make an appearance even if the
characters don't but unfortunately it
looks to be on the losing end of this
conflict there's another quick shot of
Adrian Veidt pushing the plunger of a
cartoons to hell detonator this could be
related to the people we saw on the
ground at the carnival or it could be
something else entirely there's a quick
shot of police firing a salute at the
funeral that leads into a
are looking sequence of looking-glass
surrounded by projection screens the
screen show images of cowboys soldiers
and nuclear mushroom clouds in his mass
we can see the reflection of someone
possibly Ozymandias but there's no real
way to tell and there's no explanation
for why he's sitting surrounded by these
screens next we get a look at another
new character named pirate Jenny she's
wearing a mask cocking a rifle and
heading to the back of a prisoner
transport truck she looks to be working
for the police as do all the costume
adventurers we see except for the
Rorschach's of course and it cuts back
to them as their tick-tock chant
climaxes the background sounds stop and
there's a final scene with the chief we
see that he's talking to someone
off-screen
a woman's voice asked what they're
talking about and he replies oh nothing
just the end of the world and with the
wink and a smile he adds tick tock tick
tock giving us a connection with the
Rorschach's The Watchmen HBO's season 1
trailer ends there and it gives us a lot
to speculate about I mentioned that I
would talk a little more about damon
lindelof saying that the end of the
world was off the table because i find
that interesting one of the things i
liked about the original watchmen story
is that threat of nuclear destruction
that's always looming in the background
for those of us who grew up in the 80s
this is a very real threat maybe not so
much nowadays for people who are younger
since he mentioned the end of the world
is off the table it makes you wonder
what will be the current equivalent to
that underlying threat since the
Watchmen universe is an alternate
version of our own world it'll be really
interesting to see how they use the
events that happened at the end of the
book in shaping the world that all these
new characters live in it brings up so
many questions as well
if Rorschach's journal got out and is
influencing the group of characters
going to battle with the police how is
it that Adrian Veidt is living in a
castle pushing plungers of what could be
new doomsday devices how come all the
modern costume adventurers seemed to not
just be working with the police but
actually look a lot more like police
officers first and foremost how long did
Richard Nixon remain president after
securing his third term what's up with
night al - Silk Spectre - and dr.
Manhattan are we going to see any of
those characters in the HBO series the
possibilities are endless and in all
amounts to some
to get excited about I love Damon
Lindelof slash show the leftovers and
think this has a real chance of being a
fantastic take on the time after a
really great story that was the original
watchman graphic novel I think that
Lindelof has shown that he has a real
love and respect for the source material
and I'm really curious to see how he
takes things into the future of this
watchman universe so let me know what
you think how is this universe different
than ours is that Washington Monument
actually in Washington because that
doesn't really look like the National
Mall to me will the Rorschach's be the
big bad or are they a stepping stone to
get us into the bigger story that HBO is
trying to tell let me know in the
comments let me know what questions you
have what you're excited about
and any fears you have about a new story
based in this hallowed ground of the
Watchmen universe please like the video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel I'll be doing plenty of watchman
videos throughout the time leading up to
season 1 and definitely all the way
through that's it for today thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon